so it is imperfect guess what so is
Westminster so's Whitehall so are our
political institutions I spent five
years as as deputy prime minister in
Whitehall at the end of that I came out
more anti-establishment than I went in
because I was so Paul I still AM by the
secrecy the over centralization the of
course I say this is a liberal Democrat
they lopsided an undemocratic electoral
system we have all of those things I
think of rubbish it's imperfect I want
to change but guess what I'm not going
to say in response to the imperfections
in our own political institutions we're
going to raise the whole lot to the
ground and walk off you don't do that in
life do you when something is imperfect
you recognize you try and make it better
you work with others to do so but the
idea that either sort of wash your hands
of it because you don't like its
imperfections turn your back on it pull
the drawbridge on wish it away that's
just I just don't think that is a
practical response to the realities of
the complex and interdependent world and
the complex and interdependent European
Union and the complex institutions that
govern it that we that we have here
today